when you browse the web you're not
really Browns in the way of your
fetching bits of it in looking at it
locally right so you're sending out to a
server service sending you some data
you're viewing it on your screen in your
browser you click on something it sends
another request to some server either
the same or a different one pull some
more data down you look at that on your
screen and so you've got a process for
how you send that request and then how
you get the response is sent back to you
so let's say you were to say this is
your web browser and then that's sitting
above kind of a bunch of libraries and
so what's going to happen is you've got
some data that starts out in your
browser so that's the request and then
that's going to get sent down through
these libraries eventually into the
operating system and what's going to
happen there is that this chunk which is
your original data maybe he's going to
get encoded as a TCP segment one of the
basic protocols is used for supporting
the World Wide Web so on the front of
that it's going to stick some TCP
information and then a short while later
normally what will happen is all of that
is just now thought of as data and then
you'll get some IP information on the
front of it and then a short while later
all of that will be thought of as data
and then get some Ethernet information
up front and you'll get a little bit on
the end as well and again for different
particular versions of IP so IPSec you
can end up with some information then
stuck on the end so you click on
something that's got to turn into a
Peter data the user wants to get to this
particular URL yep
then that has to go down through a bunch
of libraries so I sort of missed out a
step here but that thing there which
might just be the URL might have to get
turned into something here which is
going to be to get all right URL this is
the HTTP protocol okay so it's turned
that into this sort of more valid piece
of HTTP and then that is going to get
treated just as a chunk of data so
doesn't matter what's in there
the own URL could be an image it could
be a community you want as well a notion
of a networking stack or a protocol
stack comes from these people releasing
a stack top each of these different
layers provides a different set of
abstractions it sort of builds on the
abstractions provided by whatever's
below it and it provides some
abstraction of the thing above it for
example if you look at an Ethernet
header now I'm not gonna try and draw
all this out by memory because I will
get it wrong essentially you've got a
sequence of stuff on there so you start
out with the destination address
then you have a source address and then
depending on precisely the version of
Ethernet you're running you have some
information about the protocol of what's
coming next and then you might have some
other header information or you might
just get the data this destination
address is source address will be six
bytes each I think it's two bytes there
and then if you look inside what's
happening it this layer so it's that
that stuff there is the data that was
put in these net frame so let's say this
protocol here indicates it is actually
an IP packet is coming next and in the
IP header you'll have things like
there's a version there's a length a
source address the destination address
and then some other information that IP
needs to operate weight IP does this is
then the IP header and then eventually
you get to the data if you're
transmitting the data transmitting in
this case would start with a TCP header
not even trying to get this in the right
order now but you've got you know source
port you'll have a destination port and
some other things that TCP needs to do
the things TCP does each of these layers
is providing different features to layer
above so in the case of Ethernet for
example it provides this functionality
for going from one machine to another
machine so the addresses the users of
the MAC addresses hardware addresses
from your Ethernet card so these are the
Machine addresses it's a little bit more
fuzzy now with wireless cards because a
lot of the time you can actually set the
MAC address from software in some of
those and I can make things more complex
and opens up all kinds of security holes
and other possibilities for example but
basically yes they should be uniquely
identifying that particular network card
so there's a six bytes
they should be uniquely generated by the
manufacturer of the card so normally
speaking you split them into the first
three bytes which is which indicates
which manufacture it was so whether it's
Apple or Dell or IBM or someone and then
the other three bytes which in which is
just a counter that that manufacturer
will assign in some way
all that Ethernet really is concerned
with you getting that data from the guys
transmitting it to somebody else
connected to the same network but
immediately so getting it getting it to
an immediate neighbor so even though
it's not concerned with the internet as
a whole it's not concerned me getting
something - I don't giggle service or
something it's just concerned with
getting it to the next computer that's
on the next door computer with some kind
I pee on top of that then says okay well
the abstraction accent
provide this idea that we've got it in
the case of ipv4 we've got a bunch of
computers that are all interconnected
they can all see each other and we can
now get data to move between networks so
if it's a person the computing you want
to talk to it's not immediately adjacent
to you
IP kind of handles that and there's a
set of protocols and let IP do that by
for example figuring out that actually
if you want to get to this guy we don't
know where he is right now but what we
can do is we can send it to a Rooter
that might be bit close to the
destination and so you have this idea
that when you started out up here and
you were trying to get to Google calm as
a bunch of other translations happen and
ultimately that comes down to ethernet
layer which effectively ends up saying I
don't know how to get to Google comm by
now to get - you're hungry - you're
hungry - might know how to get home so
I'll send it there first
that's receiveth Ethernet frame then
your home router has to take off the
Ethernet bits look at the IP bits and go
okay where's this trying to get to what
should I do with it and typically your
homerooms gonna say well I don't know
how to get to google.com either in fact
at that point it's not people what com
is just address I don't know how to get
- yeah some string numbers but I do know
that this route upstream from me and
your ISPs network your internet
providers network that might have a
better idea so I'll send it there and
then that route is gonna pick it up and
it gets in there using some mean so it
might get send everything that more
likely I'll get sent there you know over
the DSL line that you've got cable modem
or something that's different set of
standards again - Ethernet so it doesn't
have to be Ethernet now that can be
something else
and that's gonna get to the root from
your internet providers network it's
gonna take off those bits that aren't
interesting anymore it's gonna look at
the IP bits and go okay well again I
don't know how to get to google.com
exactly I don't know where that is
exactly but this other route in your
internet providers Network is closer to
it so I'll send it there and it's this
sort of continual putting inside an
envelope passing it on guy takes it next
route takes a DM flows looks like it
goes that direction and it's that
sequence of things which is what causes
IP to be called a hop-by-hop network or
a store and forward Network till this
each route is kind of storing the pack
up a little bit looking at it thinking
about it it's an e-commerce place
you
we'd like to thank audible.com for
supporting this video and if you like
your books as zeros and ones and what
computerphile doesn't why not download a
free audiobook at audible.com slash
computer file
I'd recommend outliers by Malcolm
Gladwell but my taste isn't always the
best so I asked Sean who also works on
computer file and he recommended the
books by Neal Stephenson bit of an epic
series he thinks very highly of it so
why not check them out
audible.com slash computerphile you can
download a free audio book and this is
an offer for people in the US and Canada
at the moment thanks to them for
supporting our videos and thank you for
watching we'll be back soon